hey reject nation
it's Greg elbow with a love like
Colorado she's a comedian human um was
feminine body parts not relevant
irrelevant I do happen but she is that
Sarris flappers ages ago
hilarious woman I think she's still
funny I think Fosdick at Alvarado and
Twitter and Instagram cat I'll brought a
calm be on Facebook yeah no bikini pics
on Instagram sorry
there is one of me in a bathtub of hot
cheetos oh yeah and if you like it
enough or message met Instagram I'll
make sure to take more pictures in weird
soup I mean you said you lost ten pounds
recently I think we all deserve a bikini
photo well followed by you promote weird
or hybrid and today's picture the dish
after me for James deacons at the end of
this video stay tuned for that hey
there's a channel out here called mister
nightmares it's gots the number by quite
a good amount of people three true
house-sitting horror stories horror
story who does it
buildings out here
[Laughter]
nowhere a couple weeks ago my dad came
home and pitched me a small job offer
one of his co-workers was going away for
a few days and needed somebody he could
trust to watch over his house the reason
my dad each system meet was because the
man's house has a big CCTV system
basically a camera in every room and
then an operating desk where all screens
could be watched on a big monitor and
I'm a computer science manager so my dad
just always assumed that I know how to
work anything technological a man told
my dad that he paid me $200 for the two
days just to watch the house whatever
that meant my dad drove me to the house
and introduced me to the man whose name
doesn't matter the man made it seem like
he preferred a stay in the upstairs room
with the monitors as opposed to roaming
the house all day I was fine with me
though so when I wasn't eating I was
mostly just sitting in that room with
the TV on in the background and doing
schoolwork on my laptop ironically the
thing I was doing the least was keeping
an eye on the monitors night came I
started wondering where in the house
actually cleats and surprisingly we
hadn't discussed that so I sat back down
at the desk and looked at all the
different rings on the screens to see
which rooms had beds or couches
I noticed something I wasn't expecting
to notice though the back screen door
was open downstairs I didn't remember it
being open I looked through each and
every kind of screen in the panic in the
living room a closet door was open this
one I knew wasn't open earlier I texted
my dad to call the man and asked him if
he came back home meanwhile I continued
watching the screen and the grainy dark
image a tall person who resembled only a
black shadow on the screen stepped out
from the closet and closed my arms off
the desk as I covered my mouth with my
hands in shock as I did this however my
left elbow pulled some heavy objects
from the desk
we're creating a big thud the person in
the end it's very clearly moved their
head up to the ceiling as a response to
the noise they went for the stairs
walking up very very slowly step by step
meanwhile I got a text back from my dad
saying no he's not I just spoke to him
half an hour ago why I got so caught up
in my phone texting my dad to send help
that I didn't even pay attention to the
monitor there was a knock at the door I
looked at it and then the screams the
first screen I laid my eyes on was the
one showing the person outside the door
to the rear I was in when I remembered
that door had no lock
the only thing I could think to do was
jump out the window in solution below I
ran halfway down the block and then
stopped when my dad called me I had a
call his friend and asked him if he was
expecting somebody in the house the man
said he had no relatives or friends who
had his key or would ever let themselves
into his home so he called the cops and
had them review the footage I got to
watch all of it and it showed everything
from the moment the intruder broke the
glass the backyard door to the moment I
jumped out the window and him running
away shortly after the intruder was
never found the footage was just too
dark to identify his face bumpy's I'm
not letting this go story that's
something real and could happen at the
house it's very clear just for the night
okay now the Indus family were going on
a short vacation and needed somebody to
watch their pets in house I agreed to do
it for a small amount of money I've been
to his house many times before so I was
familiar with the layout
nothing eventful happened at all the
entire day I just spent the to catch the
fish and the birds I want to speak on
the council on animals my entire
community
it was Henry surrounded by good
management the think PD mounted on the
wall I fell asleep with the TV on side I
woke up not long after I turned it off
so now the room was dark I tried to go
back to sleep but I thought I heard the
sound of the PVC gate closing outside I
thought it might be just a move in the
room had windows surrounding it in three
directions so I was basically looking
around in a circle out into the darkness
I sat that down on the couch when I
calmed down when I heard a leaf
crunching outside that's what I knew
someone was out there I took another
look outside there was literally
somebody pressed up against the glass to
the window behind the couch they were
looking in and I didn't know if they
could see near that I yelled as loud as
I could at them to [ __ ] off because I
does appear to be wasn't going out there
shockingly this didn't scare the person
away in fact they walked over to the
back door and tried the door now I ran
to get the phone and then I yelled into
the sunroom I'm calling the police
thankfully this works here and no I
didn't actually call the cops Tyler said
I texted my friend just a lot of milk
and all those break-in I slept through
the night in an upstairs bedroom locked
the next morning my friends family
returns to find all the tires on their
sedan that was left behind had been
slashed we speculated that somebody who
had it out for their family and knew it
the vacation they were taking had some
kind of plan to break in and when that
failed they settled for this that's just
speculation but still it's still these
terrifying explanation to me why carry
everyone off or you play
[Music]
one more after I was in college I used
to work as a babysitter on the side to
make a little extra cash when we had saw
an aunt ocean dehydrate that was
requesting a house sitter for the
weekends and to inquire through phone I
was used to babysitting
but house-sitting sounded even better a
same thing - taking care of kids so I
called the number as soon as I got home
and spoke with a guy named Chuck I met
him that Friday and he showed me around
the house he and his wife eventually
went on their way and I was left alone
in the house I was getting one of the
spare upstairs bedrooms I saved one of
because there were a few the house was
huge nothing out of the ordinary was
going on at all for the whole day it was
quite uneventful and I felt like I was
missing out on going out so it was a
Friday night but I kept reminding myself
that I'd be making $200 for the whole
weekend later in the night I kind of
just laid in the guest bed that I'd be
sleeping in and watched a movie on
demand
I wondered why this couple felt one to
hire somebody to watch their house for
the handedness there was any pets or
anything after all though there was a
very very nice house so it seemed the
most obvious that they just wanted a
sense of security for their house while
they were gone by the time I turned off
the TV I was shot and probably minutes
away from falling asleep but the slight
sound of the click along with a sudden
blow in the room woke me completely
groan I opened my eyes slowly to see
light creeping out from under the crack
of the door it took me a second to
realize that it was a closet door I
flipped on my side as my heart started
beating 200 beats a minute I pulled the
sheets up to my chin and pretended to be
asleep I was certain someone was in that
closet and I instantly to face it
versus Larry Kansas went might beer in
that bed or how was ops chasm it and I
felt more and more like I could possibly
die the closet door opens I'm a hearing
so that could not see it as I was facing
the opposite way I closed my eyes and
tried my best not to move on would you
pretend to the room went dark again as I
heard another clicked a bit louder this
time the closet door quietly closed in
the background but I didn't hear
anything else I was afraid that whoever
it was went back into the closet I
didn't know what to do because they had
to have seen me and I didn't want to run
for it and fear of being chased the room
was dead silent as I was thinking over
my next course of action eventually I
decided to just keep over to the other
side and make sure the post it was clear
I looked on my other side someone was
standing right next to the bed and
reaching towards me my reaction I pulled
my arms out towards me balled up and
backed up onto the wall shock the person
stood there showing no signs of leaving
I hopped over the metal bar at the end
of the bed ran for the door down the
stairs and then out the front door I ran
all the way home let myself in called
Chuck and explained I told them it was
his problem now and hung up he tried
calling back but I didn't answer maybe
there was some story to be told like
they knew this person or they frequently
dealt with break-ins and that's why they
needed me I didn't care though I didn't
even care about the money I just didn't
want to speak to that chump guy ever
again
what the [ __ ] you put me up to Johnson
what's this [ __ ] you ever worry about
breaking chuck it seems like there's
look at what on
my watch automatic start my serial
yes-man I mean the first two stories
were like build up to not much happens
yeah nothing really happy first I'm like
I don't even really remember the person
but the second story was you know tidbit
of I told the guy to [ __ ] off like
that's the first thing you tell [ __ ] up
man yeah right
please gonna nothin new chest [ __ ] off I
was gonna break in the house will remain
here anymore with a third story though
man those little details it's just like
that is a good question though if you
think someone's in the closet how do you
react exactly that you just like hello
or someone there do you pretend to be
asleep and hopefully to leave or like
how do you how would you react I also
tend to be asleep so when I'm at 7:00 I
watch something on the sci-fi channel
about alien objections and so my big
fear with alien abductions okay and I
always felt like there was someone
outside my window watching me and I
would just state skills like move an
alien will get you yeah you're like the
nightmares point being if the guy wasn't
me came out of the closet I'm pretty
sure I'd be like I just stay still and
we didn't turn the light on it didn't
even say we go summer to sneak up on her
though I mean if he turns the light like
let me turn the closet light on if he's
already in the closet why do you turn
the light on if he's trying to sneak up
on her can he just like keep it open
this is the weird story turns over the
guy just to reach in his hand over her
and she's Angie manages to fly out of
the bed go over the bed run out but I'll
be a chaser grab it yeah why did he
change when he first grabber would
you're trying to get
yeah I feel like the underlying
implication and that one is either it's
Chuck and Chuck as a weirdo wants to
watch people yeah or it was like a ghost
Susie that sounds like what's the movie
the Paranormal Activity that sounds like
Paranormal Activity thing yeah that's
the movie he named it written
what's that Paranormal Activity moving
way my judgment I'll care about the
money Chuck don't talk to me a check
never diamond check again because really
like column why don't you talk to me I'm
not responsible if this is club that is
such a scary story I've never dealt an
actual breakin like staying somewhere
house sat before and sometimes house
sitting is very scared yeah you're not
familiar to here at curry yeah when I
was young it time I heard a creak I
would just stare at that section
whatever had it goes being happen to you
um one time I'm not sure if it was a
good I think it was a ghost
let me try to tell this story in the way
how he told the story I was going to
church for $200
everyone got paid the exact amount and
everybody to start when I was in eighth
grade I was in Catholic school we had a
church connected to us and I was very
much into I was in denial Gibson and Mel
Gibson had made a movie called Passion
of the Christ
oh and I was like I'm gonna go gung-ho
Jesus for everyone that so I used to go
to church by myself after school only
kid no other kid did this I would go to
church pray at church by myself but one
time I went to church and as I was
praying I heard a little girls voice go
hello and I was surrounded and seeing so
I just said hello like echoes in this
church so I heard it
I said hello my voice echoed no one
responded back I bolted the church
closing notice for I have right there
alright here's what happened
no seven I got justice all right that's
just seven you're really happy
you're praying with your eyes closed is
like a little girl and she's like
wandering around the church campus and
she's trying to find someone and she
peers into the church room it's a
sanctuary where we're going to talk to
you that
yeah buddy nice very good one there she
closed the door and go baby and you're
like I hope I'm actually sounds like a
much more realistic sin are all these
years I thought moving together like not
minimizing like I'm on the hunt for real
ghosts okay personally I was really
hoping and not that I saw death up here
what was do you have a ghost story
breaking in story no not really
okay what I have so I lived in the tops
I was renting a room is up in
Carpinteria which is like near Santa
Barbara I was here just like right
around midnight I would hit he's like
like shuffle like sounds in my room like
a bag would move something like that for
a year every month or so I was here this
little sound and I was like man I think
my choice is haunted and I was dating a
guy and he slept over and he was like
yeah I do feel a presence in this room
now but he was like very spiritual he
broke up with me to join a monastery
that's another story a couple months
later after that I am in the kitchen and
I see a rat who confronts across the
floor like oh snap I was like I wonder
if that's it and then I go over and the
next day I'm like in my room on my
computer and I turn around and I see
this little thing like scampering across
making noise walking across bags under
my bed like scampering around like this
[ __ ] was my quivering sense to
presence it was a rat it wasn't a mouse
turns out I already joined the monastery
but yeah hope that wasn't like that
resident
that creature was an animal
wasn't it go I'm on the hostel I hope I
can find a real ghost our soda
none of our stories went off to anything
good
well I'm good shut up Stan Holly fail
[Laughter]
subscribe to the real real subscribe to
mr. nightmare quick that notification
valve get Alvarado is the cat Alvarado
on Twitter and Instagram and she is
getting a lot of comedy on Facebook go
check her out there and be sure to be
shout out James Higgens today James
Tegan is a longtime follower of this
channel vegan how does that mean I don't
know but probably someone with a high
school with probably her what is sorry
to assume your dating life would just be
that way darling you're a [ __ ] we're
good
well they're really good at that they're
not Fargo them a powder in our school
kitchen in promise what is James mean
that sounds a lot easier to work up new
king Jacob your name another
neighborhood sup one Turk the plan size
it possible answer he killed no one who
follows ah some sander did not attend to
that you meant to be a follower your
whole life word you know what it's not
the bad thing tomorrow I've heard once
every great leader was once a great
follower and I also heard this that's
[ __ ] but you know what good for you
you can find that if it's true or not
you can tell it hope you appreciate your
shout have at it